and that crazy guy reached into the boat
yeah that was that was creepy you have
to see it I was pretty creepy I have to
see it I was like what it what is the
meaning of these these people that are
crazy that don't like what I was trying
to figure out like a metaphor or some
[ __ ] and I was like man this is just
some this is just some dumb dumb people
deep [ __ ] here's someone I know there's
like deep EDS I know that [ __ ] guy on
Twitter the rap dude the guy who can
cook and whatever and you know it's
still single somehow good idea yeah I
know he watched that movie and when it
ended he was like damn that shit's about
social media the metaphor is just a
snapchat dick pics yeah you have to see
it over your eyes you have to see it
lady open your eyes you have to see it
come on just look just look it's
beautiful come on and then everyone's
huge everyone who sees it wants to kill
herself because she's so tired of come
on it's like it's pretty big likes
bigger than average hey dude
the I mean just think about the words
these women chose when they'd before
they died like one of them call out for
her mom like please save me mommy show
me his penis mm-hmm Sandra Bullock's
sister she all she said was you know
pretty good reaction did it's gotta be a
pretty brutal dick yeah to make to make
women jump in front of drugs you gotta
have a bad dick dig so better inspire
suicide
it's a superpower you have a pretty bad
it's just a villain with the [ __ ]
worst dick no he's got like pants like
with a hole in him he moves around on a
chair with his legs crossed real tight
real tight not like open and
businesslike like over the knee yeah
hello tight just sit around and like a
dr. Xavier type chair give me the money
or I open my legs and what's that gonna
do
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he will light up in flames looking at it
you know to the to this point that's the
worst dick I've ever seen to this point
I did some dr. bad dick yeah there you
go all right we're gonna stay with it
fuggee a dr. bad dick doctor doctor BD
BD looks too bad dick you think it's
gonna be big dick energy yeah but it's
bet ya you've got that bad energy bad
dick dude dr. bad day that's how I'm
living that's how I'm coming 2019 bad
dick energy all of dr. bad dicks minions
like their eyes are like black just cuz
like their burned out from looking at
his dick and that this they have hyper
sensitive like smell and scent like
hearing like a stray dog
it's weird patches of hair is any too
skinny and it's got like like like
growths on it it's got like spores
emitting it just looks like wheezing the
pokémons balls look like dr. bad day all
this means is human werewolves he just
comes no warning at all just falls on
the ground
yeah just looks like it's trail of sad
calm it looks like boogers just not just
dr. bad dick doctor dr. bad dick bad
dick energy 2019 baby that's where it is
it's where we're at you get nervous in
public bad dick energy yeah you got that
bad dick mm-hmm girls say please stop
damning me that's that bad dick bad dick
energy yeah you'll get the callback
that's that bad that's not a play